that John Donner I should write a book
on dating and that would be chapter one
Embrace being a beginner chapter two
will be bear versus lion
pivot quickly to Violence by the way we
totally skipped over Anaconda
I I assumed the implied
uh uh I'll I'll put it to this way
on video you can watch Puma yeah and and
um uh similar sized cats
uh Jaguar destroy anacondas even in
water which is the anaconda's preferred
domain so
given that
puma and and jaguar are several orders
below lion you have to go with the idea
that a lion would utterly decimate
Anaconda so it's probably good that we
did skip over it and I think uh going
back to the original thought that you
had about this don't trust your first
instinct books I think about the other
elements and Anaconda has no ability to
disengage from the fight
once the flight's on it's got to go
until the end it has no ability to
disengage and get away
um its only hope would be Ambush and
it's got
a tiny tiny chance against
yeah a truly formidable animal and the
fact that if we look at actual concrete
real world results when when puma and
jaguar are kicking their ass you know
lion and bear it's going to be a lot
worse
science is not to be found on YouTube or
rather YouTube is not science I bet you
there's a bear
somewhere in Canada that has seen some
[ __ ] I'm just gonna leave it at that